you know we're human beings that are
capable of changing right and
when you label a human being as an int
and saying you're not good at that focus
on what you're good at and you tell
yourself that story well that becomes
your truth
right i'm not good at numbers or i'm not
good at sales well then
you can be you just have to work at it's
just practice right
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with ctec hiring is
hard
kovid made it somewhat easier somewhat
harder
but definitely showed us that there are
opportunities to make it more scalable
showed us that there are different
biases that go into the hiring process
and that is exactly
what i'm talking about today with paul
bilado ceo and founder at filtered ai
paul bilodo is the ceo and founder of
filtered ai a capabilities-based hiring
platform designed specifically for
engineers
developers and tech talent that helps to
remove unconscious bias from the hiring
process through assessments and coding
tasks
paul started his professional career as
a recruiter for a leading recruitment
firm in boston
it wasn't long before he identified
major disconnects and
inefficiencies when it came to the
hiring process
so in 2010 he created pangaea connect a
video interviewing platform
soon after he co-founded data science
consulting company
refactor ed and built filtered as an
internal tool to ensure candidate
authentication
and more accurately assess candidates
technical skills
in 2018 the demand to license filtered
as a standalone product led to the
establishment of filtered inc
and the continued drive to radically
change the hiring process
paul bilado welcome to 20 minute leaders
all the way from boston how are you
i'm good michael i'm happy to join i'm
really happy that you're here
and you know we thought about the
connection
with entering just a second ago and i'm
really excited to hear about
what you're doing with filtered.ai and
and before we dive into the recruiting
space
and and you know the unconscious vices
that we may have in the hiring and
and the way data science plays into all
of it i want to hear a little bit about
about your journey into this because
what i love hearing is how people got to
where they are and it sounds like
you didn't just come up with this idea
and on a bright shiny day
it actually evolved with your
experiences from
these different sectors so so paul tell
me a little bit about your story and how
did you get into
founding filter.ai
uh so basically um
we were uh we started a data science
consulting company in 2015
and um we were trying to scale up teams
um and uh
you know we were doing the interview
process and so
two phone screens before a personal
round of interviews looking at resumes
having people come on site or doing
something remote like this and
and having some sort of technical
exercise
that was uh subjective at best um
and realizing that uh
a lot of what we thought about the
technical performance on the on the
exercise that we had
um was uh due to bias
right so we fall back to the resume and
you know that no one from that company
is any good
no one from that school is any good or a
flip side it's
we noticed how there could be you know
false positives you know if somebody
worked at amazon you wouldn't question
the solution
like or in certain teams or apple or
google
and uh and meanwhile i looked at my
partners like well
you know if we hadn't worked together
you'd have never hired me i'm an
econ major and uh you know another thing
that we realized was
uh also was like just structuring an
interview and and getting out of this
what you know what we wanted to and so
um
so yeah that's kind of where where it
all started and and uh
and the other thing was like look we're
going through all these steps in the
process to realize that
they can't do the work uh in the final
step of the process
like if we were hiring a chef would we
go through all these steps to realize
they couldn't cook
after four rounds of interviews or
should we just make them cook eggs first
and then enter the hiring funnel and
that's kind of where it all started
really okay so so taking the higher you
know into the
hiring world and the recruiting world
that you're in right now obviously
things have
shifted dramatically over this past year
and
but but it sounds to me like that what
you're describing the process
is pretty similar to also what's
happening today maybe now it's happening
more remotely but
but it sounds like a pretty cumbersome
process that at the end doesn't actually
give a strong enough signal
as to whether this is the right
candidate for you and it just creates a
bad experience for all parties involved
with with a
often a bad outcome as well so what what
is
sort of the hiring process that you're
observing and that you're also trying to
change
through filtered dot ai and how does the
ai's
part help you do that yeah so um
so we've uh we sit in front of the job
application
in most cases and uh resumes are never
reviewed
and so that's a big shift in what we're
doing and and really what we've found
uh is that the you know the app
contracting systems and
that are in place that are matching
keywords from a job description that
90 percent of the time the hiring
manager didn't write
um is matching to a resume in order to
shortlist
right and so the folks that are getting
shortlisted
um are usually just adding keywords
right and so they're gaming the system
and the folks that actually did the job
aren't doing it and so you're screening
in the wrong people and screening out
the right people right so that's you
know that's where we started
and um and there's also we can anonymize
it
right so you could see hr could see pii
data or video questions
uh in a resume whereas you know sharing
with the hiring team maybe they only see
a technical exercise and
surprise there's where diversity comes
from
um you know and even starting with you
know some highly progressive
large technical teams in the valley
whereas we only hire phds from top
schools in this team and then
you know within 90 days it wasn't you no
longer needed a phd
from a top school we didn't need a phd
to get hired in that team so
um and really the ai for us has to do
around
um well one it was around fraud right
and so
uh with take-home there's a lot of fraud
uh and so
it was you know coding similarities um
is it the same person taking the
interview i mean things that we didn't
think would have to build
but you know somebody did a video
portion and then that's a different
person doing coding
and or someone or someone you see me
and then i hand over my laptop to
somebody else sitting next to me on the
couch and then
finishing the exercise that's really
kind of where it starts
that that you've observed happening i
wasn't even i didn't even think of that
of hiring uh i didn't either um
i didn't realize at this scale uh and so
even today when you're using filtered
for a take-home challenge and there's
two different versions there's a
take-home and then there's
um then there's a live version which is
similar to this
but in recorded uh with coding pads like
an id
integrated as well as jupiter and r
studio so you can do
an exercise here um
but uh 11 of the time there's two faces
on the screen or the face changes during
the technical
portion of the exercise and so we know
coding behaviors
you know around we're not just doing
inputs and outputs we're scoring
you know is the code maintainable can
you understand it
and uh you know how many lines of code
did it take to solve the problem because
you know if you're not evaluating the
coding behaviors as well as the scores
um they're not really solving the
problem here because you know for
example like in a former life as a
basketball player
and um if we shoot free throws right uh
and we both hit 9 out of 10 but i shot
underhand
am i really as good as you are right and
so we kind of see that behavior
that makes a lot of sense i'm here i'm
hearing a few different things i'm
hearing
both this idea of okay so we have the
resumes and we have the whole projection
of of the whole short listing
and then we have the actual you know
onboarding and actual investigation is
this the right candidate for us
and it sounds to me but but tell me more
yourself
what has been happening over this past
year from your perspective as more and
more when remote i'm guessing that the
problem just
became worse because everything because
everything
went remote and people didn't know how
to adapt but what have you been
observing on this
on actual field yeah the first so the
first thing when
shelter in place happened um
the first thing was uh well the 470 000
recruiting coordinators who are
responsible for
scheduling interviews with a candidate
going to meet them at the front
desk walking them in put them in a
conference room
going to get the first interviewer
knocking on the window and there's five
minutes remaining and they're going to
get the next person
and then debriefing and locking them out
that doesn't exist and then there's high
transaction costs
when it comes to scheduling right and
gathering feedback so
we built live rooms with uh like it's a
hiring workspace
really and so it has workflows so that
um
if i need five more minutes for the kid
i press but
um it's also transcribed we have some
analysis on it
and so we're analyzing the interview as
well right and so
and really what we're trying to do there
is is is to
like stop subjective interviews like do
structured interviewing like if
you know you have multiple teams in in
the same company
hiring the same skill set asking
different questions even though they're
doing most the same thing
and when you receive feedback such as oh
you know i just didn't get a good
feeling well that means
you're not actually interviewing you're
talking about
um you know questions that uh really
aren't gonna
you know that create bias really like
how did you like working at this company
and things of that nature so we're
analyzing those questions we're also
um you know if it's a if it's a panel
interview
and three people on my team have
had like really like the candidate i get
a notification that
instead of doing the interview
i'm supposed to sell the candidate right
shifting gears right away
so that i know like i'm not letting you
walk away with
uh well they just grilled me for four
hours
and didn't sell me on the opportunity i
don't even know how it is to work there
i'm not going to take that role
right and so it's really kind of being
able to be actionable during the process
that's really interesting because i i
heard you know on one hand this idea of
moving from subjective to objective and
understanding that we have these
different biases
and i'm really into behavioral economics
all these cognitive biases that you have
with us
constantly they're they're hindering our
ability to really measure the candidate
in an honest way
yeah at the same time i'm hearing that
you actually need that objectivity in
the beginning phase
to be able to move to the more personal
aspect which is the actual onboarding
and actually
once you reach the right candidate
giving them that good experience right
yes yes yeah correct um because you're
hiring humans right
uh anybody look at the process for most
of these companies
we can't attract good people we hear
from digital transformation fortune 500
which is where we started
it's not that you can't attract good
people it's your process
and if you want to attract the folks
from
the things of the world then have them
in
the interact with code first or doing an
exercise with because that's what you're
doing there you're not talking to
someone and talent acquisition who asks
why do you want to work here and
technical questions they don't know the
answers to and
that takes 20 days to schedule that
right
um so i think it's more of a flawed
process
than anything and so trying to humanize
this process
using ai which is kind of an oxymoron
but that's
right so what is the biggest challenge
here
when you're you're talking about
humanizing through ai
and and rethinking the funnel from the
resume all the way to
the selling point of the candidate you
know was you're observing this whole
funnel
what what's the hardest thing to crack
here
is change right um you know selling into
uh companies that have been doing
things for the same way for 30 years
right
um i'd have to go to the board of
directors to change our
job application process even though they
know it's broken until only 10
of the applicants finish the process um
you know so it's introducing change and
it's also um
ai can feel like automation of your job
and it's not you know so there's a lot
of fear uh in the industry and it's
really
about helping them to understand like
we're gonna help you cast a wider net
we're not replacing you we're making you
more efficient
at your job by helping you do it on
scale
right and is this do you see this
specifically relevant for
more of engineering type jobs where you
can easily
quantifiably measure one candidate
versus another
what about the other you know i don't
know 70 or 80 percent
of of the positions that that also
i'm guessing have a broken system of
hiring and of measuring
even probably more broken because they
don't have a lot of the
of the basic tools that tech companies
today have
yeah so i mean we started in engineering
um
just dog fooding it and and
like we've and also we're under the
guise of
um you know as
things are being automated right and and
uh jobs are changing
there's more technical jobs right so
like even in marketing the the second
most desired skill now is
is data right um financial analysts have
to write sql
right and so you're beyond like
non-technical jobs are now requiring
technical skills
and so um we've looked at other areas
uh around uh evaluation but then you're
getting it
what we it has to be a practical
exercise right
and they wish we could do it with sales
i mean uh we did a lot of interviews
internally for sales folks um but
you know i don't believe uh in the
myers-briggs
and those personality types i think
they're
general enough so you believe in them
and like a horoscope um but you know so
you get the barnum effect
and i also believe that these systems
you know we're human beings that are
capable of changing
right and when you label a human being
as an
int and saying you're not good at that
focus on what you're
good at and you tell yourself that story
well that becomes your truth
right i'm not good at numbers or i'm not
good at sales so then
you can be you just have to work at it's
just practice right
um but yeah i mean so we have
looking at you know if it's project
manager maybe it's looking at a document
and then
and then a project plan and and and
highlighting areas where they would
start first
right or problem resolution and things
of that nature
tell me a little bit about the
onboarding so you come to a company
some some of your clients are big
clients you're coming there and
you're saying listen everyone we have
this this new way of thinking
and you know look at our insights you
know
and and i'm guessing sometimes your
insights are contradictory to what their
gut feelings are telling them
about perhaps a specific person how do
you then manage that
yeah so um we have a lot of interesting
data um
like so uh
we will show up with pass and fail rates
based on
day and time of the week but that
normalizes by the end of the week so we
know the worst
times for candidates in days and times
for candidates to interview
conversely also know the best days the
higher pass rates
and you don't pick up on that because
again it's
it's the it's the week or the month and
it's just normalized but the worst
time of uh the worst day of the week to
interview is
is monday morning right for the
candidate it sounds great scheduling it
but you know
the case of the mondays um right and
or before lunchtime right and so like at
11 o'clock
and uh because we're humans and we have
hormones like you get hungry
and then your perception of the
candidate changes so that's again it's
not objective uh when you start to show
your insights
study with a with a court and they found
that judges are much more likely
to um to give a larger sentence
to a potential criminal if it's right
before lunchtime
and has a lot of the same biases that we
were just talking about
yeah it's similar to um you know like
back in the day
um you know when you're buying an
automobile like don't buy the one that
was built on a friday
you know um so to be have more floss
yeah so again we're humans and so those
insights help to kind of show
oh yeah actually as yeah that does
happen or
um you know so it's really kind of
winning them over and
um and also it's the candidate
experience right
so right um it's you know we have 80
completion rates uh for taking a filter
versus
an average of 20 filling like you're
finishing an online job application
wow okay that's incredible because at
the end it's it's not just about whether
the candidate
is the right candidate or not it's about
creating this funnel that is friendly
enough to capture
both types of candidates so that you
don't miss out on them but then
having it be solid enough to actually be
able to make to make those interesting
choices i i i have a few fun questions
for the end but but a little bit of a
deeper one before that
from from basketball player uh both in
college and overseas and getting injured
but then moving into
consulting and and then data science and
now further
what is it about this issue that you're
trying to solve that that really gets
you excited that you're saying this
is the problem that i want to be working
on on a daily basis
yeah um so i think the problem
is giving people a shot i think that
they're very talented people that don't
give an opportunity
based on you know how their lot in life
like where they were born where they
went to school i mean that
when you you this starts when you're
young a lot younger
and it prevents you or it makes it hard
it doesn't prevent you like we're again
we can work hard and practice
um but it's creating a bridge right and
um
i mean i think you know even our team
like everybody
you know from engineering is has to take
a filtered and and when we were being
evaluated
uh you know going through due diligence
the feedback was you don't pay enough
for engineering
you you should it's a third based on
your team size what we would see
in the valley so they needed to do a
code review
to make sure it was real and scalable
and that was really just the bias right
it's like we're hiring for what we need
and we're not over you know we don't
need to check all like do consensus
right consensus hiring uh checking all
these boxes for where we are today
we know what areas we need to cover and
we know how to evaluate that
and um and people are hungry right like
um giving people the opportunity
um that maybe they wouldn't have
received based on if it was a resume
like if you're evaluating resumes paul
are you ready for a few fun questions i
have three fun
difficult non-committal questions okay
okay all right number one yes favorite
subject in school
k-12 your choice
ah
history i love it
any specific history point
um i liked early american history i'm
i i really like the some lessons around
you know leadership
uh lessons uh but yeah that was kind of
my most most favorite
wonderful one of role models that you
look up to
professionally personally
um yes i'm gonna wow um
well you know i played basketball right
so um
if i go back to somebody had an impact
in my life
you know it was um you know as my as my
coach
you know from prep school max good um
that really influenced me and as
a role model and really taught me how to
be a man um at a young age
um i had a big ego in basketball and
in high school and i'm you know teaching
that me that you know how you behave
represents you know
your friends your family your teammates
and so it wasn't about
you know you making a mistake and
apologizing um
and taught me that hard work was the way
was kind of the way forward so
um you know that's another thing that i
haven't been able to shut off
my if you asked my wife uh and i
probably you know
we share the bed with filtered and
filtered and sleeps in between us
but you know it taught me focus i love
it okay
last question three words that you would
choose
to describe yourself
ah uh pragmatic
um you're generous
i'm inauthentic
pragmatic generous and authentic paul
thank you very very much for joining me
from boston i really thank you so much
filtered i i love the idea of of using
ai to humanize the process giving a fair
shot
okay you know trying to trying to to
lower the cognitive devices that we that
we bring to the table so that we can
actually
bring on the right people and and and do
the right process both efficiently but
also in a way that's a win-win for
everybody
paul thank you very much and stay safe
thank you appreciate it
take care it's great meeting you thanks
for having me appreciate it
[Music]